I I believe that the Quran is the final
revelation of God is because I believe
that it contains content that only God
could have known. You guys obviously
agree because I believe in 2 Peter it
actually says explicitly that everything
that is prophetic and spoken from a
prophet is going to be initially from
the Holy Spirit, right? That's written
in 2 Peter. So if there is prophetic
content and so on and so forth according
to you guys, it's going to be coming
from God. There's a multitude of reasons
why I also believe in this, but I want
to hear your thoughts. Why don't you
guys believe that the Quran is the final
revelation
>> Notice the the distortion,
the twisting, the perversion of 2 Peter
1:20 to 21.
All right, 2 Peter 1:20 to 21.
Y'all let you hear her argument, but pay
attention. There's two clips we're going
to play.
She claims cuz the Quran is prophetic.
Okay, understand the argument.
The Quran is prophetic,
right?
And according to Peter in 2 Peter,
all prophecy is from the Holy Spirit.
Now, I didn't watch the interview.
What you're going to learn here, son of
his right hand Yeshua Messiah, good to
see you.
What you're going to learn here is how
not to interpret the Bible, how to
interpret the Bible, learn your Bible,
learn context. Nina, how are you,
sister? Okay? Let me repeat.
98, 99% of the objections are refuted by
just going to the chapter and reading
the context. Let me repeat.
98, 99% of the objections are destroyed
just by going to the chapter. Say, "Hey,
let's open up the chapter."
And reading the context, it will
destroy,
it will demolish, it will obliterate
all objections and expose the lies and
the falsehood of all these religious
systems. I got to go off camera for a
second, but you can still hear my voice.
Okay?
The problem is now I didn't watch the
debate.
So I don't know if they caught her.
But I will let you see how the sister
answered.
She says that the story of Joseph and
the Quran Surah till Yusuf.
So this young sister knew
about the Quran
supposedly confirming the Bible but then
contradicting
the content of the Bible by narrating
stories
that are found in the Bible
but in conflict. You're going to hear
the Christian sister if she is a
Christian sister. I don't know if she
believes in Trinity.
Saying well the Quran says it comes to
confirm the Bible.
Chapter 12 of the Quran called the
chapter of Joseph Surah till Yusuf. It's
supposedly narrating
the story of Joseph in Genesis. Do you
want to read the story of Joseph in
Genesis?
You start at Genesis 37 all the way to
chapter 50. She goes however the Quran
contradicts the details of the story of
Joseph in the Bible that the Quran
supposedly confirms therefore cannot be
prophetic. You understand?
Good. I'm proud of her.
So 70 weeks everyone understand
what Bella's response was? I didn't know
her name was Bella.
Now that is an excellent response. The
only problem is
unless
I have to go back and see more of the
context
nobody in this clip nailed her on
misquoting 2 Peter 1.
So now let's see her repeat
that if the Quran is prophetic
Peter in 2 Peter says all prophecies
from the Holy Spirit then the conclusion
is the Quran is from God from the Holy
Spirit. Why don't you accept it?
Okay? Do you understand our objection?
Let her repeat it. If there is prophetic
content and so on and so forth,
according to you guys, it's going to be
coming from God. There's a multitude of
reasons why I also believe Not according
to us. That's a misrepresentation of the
Christian position. So, you're going to
learn your Bible. You're going to learn
exegesis. You're going to learn about
prophecy. Just be patient. in this, but
I want to hear your thoughts. Why don't
you guys believe that the Quran is the
final revelation of God? Yeah, and I
actually told almost agree with you. So,
the miracle of the Quran is that
Muhammad is like illiterate, but he gets
all these things right, right? And I
don't want to talk about the theology
that he gets right or you know, morals
that he gets right. I want to talk about
the stories of the prophets cuz the
Quran has 6,000 and plus verses and it
contains 1,100 verses about stories of
the prophets. That's a whole 1/6 of the
Quran, meaning if he gets any of those
1/6 of the Quran You're saying her name
is Bella?
I don't know the people here. I know
you'll see
Lady Logic is here. stories wrong, then
he's not a prophet, right? And so, for
example, in uh 12:3, uh this is the
chapter of Joseph, right? Allah is
saying, "Before this, Muhammad, you
didn't know anything about the story of
Joseph." And then he reveals 98 verses
in detail about Joseph.
Man, this girl's uh pretty sharp. She
even
counted the verses. So, she's an
apologist. She's Trinitarian?
Okay. 98 verses in detail. I'm pretty
impressed.
And he closes this chapter in verse 111
by saying, "This is a confirmation of
the previous scriptures and a detailed
explanation of all things." So, it's a
confirmation also in its details. And
so, I read the 98 verses, but then when
I go and I search the Torah's version of
Joseph, I find incredible amounts of
differences. And they're irreconcilable,
too. You know, sometimes it's like, "Oh,
maybe he was this age and like it may
No, like they're irreconcilable. And
there's 944 differences just in those 98
verses of Joseph. 944 differences.
That's This woman has done her homework,
huh? Now, I have to fact-check her, of
of course, but impressive.
And to me, that that's really hard to
reconcile. Um and the only reason
Muhammad would be a a true prophet
revealing the correct Quran is that if
the Quran's account of the prophets do
match up and you probably know verse
10:94. Yes, I do.
>> if you're in doubt, go and read or go
and ask
>> to ask those who read the scriptures.
Exactly. And the context of that is
right before it's stories of Moses,
Noah, Jacob. Sorry, not Jacob. Moses,
Aaron, Noah, other prophets and then
like when the Israelites like said
Absolutely spot on, man. She's very
smart. I'm impressed.
Very smart. May God keep these young
people
pure and holy and keep us pure and holy,
per- perfect their theology,
perfect our obedience and I pray that
for us. Bring them to the fullness of
the truth. All right. And we are in the
promised land all these things which are
all stories you can find in the Old
Testament. And so, if the people in the
7th century are in doubt that Muhammad
revealing all these stories of the
prophets, they have to go read the
previous scripture. And so, when we go
and look at not only the 7th century
text, but the Dead Sea Scrolls from the
250s and the 1st century and not even
even extra biblical texts, right? You
have Philo of Alexandria, he's a Greek
philosopher, no motive for religion. Um
you have the Roman
I don't know what she meant, no motive
for religion. Philo was a
devout Alexandrian Jew. He tried to use
philosophy to convince the Jews of the
truth of the Old Testament and that God
spoke through the prophets like Moses.
So, I don't know what she means no
religion, but nonetheless. historian
Josephus and then you have the Codex
Alexandrinus, Syriac Peshitta, and
Syriac, Greek, Latin, all these
different all these different languages
all talking about the same story of
Joseph way before Muhammad's time.
Muhammad comes with 98 verses of
complete contradiction. The main reason
Okay.
Let's sum up what our argument is again.
All right. Let's sum up what the
argument is.
Second Peter 1 says prophecy is from the
Holy Spirit. Guys, please learn the
objection. Prophecy is from the Holy
Spirit.
The Quran is prophetic. Therefore, the
Quran must be from the Holy Spirit, must
be from God. Do you understand the logic
there?
Do you understand the logic, right?
We're going to play two clips.
Second Peter 1. She didn't say where,
but it's 1:20 to 21.
Prophecy is from the Holy Spirit.
Quoting Peter.
The Quran is prophetic. It has prophecy.
So, the conclusion is the Quran must be
from God, must be from the Spirit.
I mean
I feel bad that she appealed to Second
Peter, cuz she now is going to end up
proving Muhammad is an Antichrist. This
is how you learn how to refute. God
bless Bella.
She went a different route, which is
good, but let me train you
as the Spirit has trained me and the
Spirit working through me to train you.
Remember, and I mean this, I am your
brother in the Lord Jesus, your servant.
I pray I am a Christian.
Look to the Spirit as our teacher
working through humans. I don't want you
to be associated with me. Okay?
Now
I'm laughing that she go to Second
Peter.
She go to Second Peter. Now
here's the thing.
I'm going to try to help you make the
most effective destruction
demolishment of Islam and all other
false religions
by learning how to refute objections.
If she goes to Second Peter 1
before you go into the Quran
and how it contradicts the biblical
story, say, "Can we look at Second Peter
1?
Now, let's see what Cora the tame me did
not
note or focus on here. First, let's read
what she's quoting. Ready?
Second Peter 1:20 to 21.
You ready?
2nd Peter 1:20-21. This is how you're
going to do it, right guys? Learn
to give the most effective destruction,
obliteration of opposing views in order
to silence their
blasphemies and lies. Take them captive
and bring them to the feet of the Lord
Jesus Christ. Please learn. Here is how
you do it. Righteous from Sheikh
everyone learning? Okay.
Here's what he quotes. 2nd Peter
1:20-21. Know this first of all, let me
start at 19.
And we have as more sure the prophetic
word
to which you do well to pay attention as
to a lamp shining in a dark place
until the day dawns and the morning star
rises in your hearts. Now, I love the
metaphors and the imagery of the Bible.
Your Bible's supernatural.
Supernaturally designed by the spirit.
Now,
what is Peter saying?
The world is steeped in spiritual
darkness. It's under the influence of
the prince, the ruler of darkness.
But the prophetic word is your light
that shines in the darkness for you to
escape the darkness and find your way
home to the Lord Jesus Christ.
Okay. Now, you see what I'm saying?
The prophetic word.
The word God has revealed. The
proclamation of what he has done and
what he will do.
And this is the light that will keep you
safe
from the darkness, being swallowed by
the darkness until
the day dawns, the morning star rises in
your hearts. Now, let me explain what
that means. The morning star also
would be the plan Well, in ancient
cultures, Venus the planet was known as
the morning star, evening star.
The morning star is the star that you
see right when dawn breaks and
destroying the darkness. But now, fact
check me.
It is always darkest
right before the dawn sets
and destroys the darkness.
Now, you know what Peter Peter is
saying?
The morning star that arises,
the day star that arises to shine and
destroy the darkness is the Lord Jesus
Christ in his return to the earth.
Christ will physically bodily descend.
And being the light of the world, he is
the son of righteousness, S-U-N, who
arises like the sun in the sky
with healing in his rays.
When he arises,
when he shines, when he descends, he
will destroy the darkness of the earth
and there'll be no more darkness.
Does it now make sense, the language
Peter is using?
The prophetic word, a lamp, daybreaks,
morning star rises.
Fact check me. It is always darkest, the
darkest period of the night is right
before dawn. And then, when dawn breaks,
you see what they call the morning star.
When you see the morning star, you know
the night is about to disappear.
So, when you see heavens open and the
light of Jesus shining, you know Jesus,
the morning star, is descending. He will
destroy all evil, wickedness,
immorality, remove the evil from the
earth, and transform the earth where
it'll just be righteousness, holiness,
purity, deathlessness.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, everyone got that?
You understand what he's saying?
So, what's his point? His point is this.
Let me explain his point.
His point is
if you do not focus on the prophetic
word.
Right?
See, brother?
Now, you see how beautiful and perfect
the metaphors and the parables and the
similes and the symbolism
inspired by the Holy Spirit happen to
be, how precise and perfect they are?
Okay.
Okay. Now, let me explain what he means.
And all of you can can identify with
this. So, everyone listen up. Each of
everyone else suck everyone.
His point is the world will swallow you
up in darkness
because of the trials, tribulations,
temptations, betrayals.
It will eat you alive and spit you out
unless you meditate on the word of God
by
focusing on the word, meditating on the
word.
The word will give you strength,
courage, and hope not to falter, not to
despair, and not to sink.
Do you know when believers start
sinking? This is in my own life. When I
start focusing on my problems, focusing
on my situation, focusing on the fear of
let's say losing support, not having
enough to take care of my daughters,
then I start becoming weak and carnal.
But, the moment I start focusing on the
word, meditating on the word, going to
church, then I'm strong again.
This is what Peter is warning you.
Peter is warning you
because Peter himself experienced it.
Focus on the prophetic word.
It is a light that will swallow up the
darkness around you, so you don't get
engulfed by it, start faltering. But,
the moment you spend less time praying,
studying the word, meditating on the
word, hearing the word, fellowshipping
Christians,
that is the moment you're going to get
weaker and weaker and more sinful and
more bitter and more doubtful.
You understand?